[Musica]
[Applauso]
secondo voi nel mondo ci sono più
persone buone o più persone cattive da
un recente sondaggio che ho fatto sulla
mia pagina instagram
sembra che il popolo sia divisa
completamente in due con una leggera
prevalenza per i buoni mentre mi sarei
aspettato una vittoria molto maggiore in
parte meno sono giustificate dal fatto
che i miei coetanei sono cresciuti come
me con vent'anni di notizie di
telegiornali tendenzialmente negativa e
quindi potrebbero avere una visione
anche un po più pessimistica del futuro
a questa cosa mi ha fatto pensare a un
analisi che ho studiato quando ho fatto
una breve esperienza alla singolare di
universit in america nel centro ricerca
della nasa dove ci hanno fatto vedere
delle immagini satellitari di interi
palazzi all'interno dei quali esistono
delle persone che tutto il giorno si
occupano di fare degli attacchi
informatici
basti pensare a uno di questi attacchi
che risale al 2017 si chiamavano cry e
ha colpito è infettato più di 200 mila
computer
inoltre 106 paesi questo è un caso
perfetto di viralità seppure nella sua
declinazione peggiore è un altro caso
che mi fa essere abbastanza pessimista
lo ha visto recentemente quando alcuni
ragazzi forse per gioco hanno deciso di
installare su un drone un ak47 hanno
pubblicato in rete questo video di
questo drone che andava in giro a
sparare ad altri droni nella stessa area
nello stesso momento però in questi anni
ho voluto dedicare molto tempo a provare
a studiare tutti i casi di utilizzo
della tecnologia per generare un impatto
sociale positivo perché sono convinto
che sono molti di più ma talvolta non
hanno la stessa visibilità mediatica e
in particolare sono state la più
importante fiera dell'innovazione in
america al sia stata sveglia e dove ho
conosciuto un ragazzo asiatico che aveva
inventato il primo bambino
radiocomandato quindi una ciambella che
è in grado di viaggiare a 10 metri al
secondo sull'acqua andando a salvare una
persona maniera molto più veloce di un
bagnino tradizionale soprattutto senza
dover mettere a rischio la vita di un
uomo per andarmene
a salvare un altro e potrei raccontarvi
tantissimi esempi di tecnologie
utilizzate in questa maniera
io mi occupo specificatamente di social
media e anche quando si parla di social
molte persone tendono a dare dei
commenti abbia abbastanza negativi su
come questi strumenti impattano la vita
di tutti noi mentre dovremmo ogni tanto
anche cercare di vedere gli aspetti
positivi come il fatto che due settimane
fa è uscita la notizia del traguardo di
2 miliardi di dollari che sono stati
raccolti all'interno di facebook grazie
alle micro donazioni di milioni di
utenti sono dunque convinto che la
maggior parte di noi potrebbe essere
definita come dei buoni dormienti
quindi noi dentro di noi ci sentiamo
buoni ma siamo semplicemente inattivi
perché completamente distratti dai tanti
impegni quotidiani e potrebbe talvolta
bastare una scintilla per attivare
quello che sentiamo di dover fare dentro
di noi per fare qualcosa di positivo
come possiamo dunque attivare queste
scintille positive sono convinto che non
possiamo attivarle se continuiamo a
stare chiusi all'interno della nostra
stanza senza andare a prendere
all'interno all'esterno della nostra
stanza qualcosa di positivo
dobbiamo dunque essere sicuramente molto
curiosi per andare all'esterno a cercare
nuovi stimoli nuove scintille magari
proprio in questo momento in alcune
parti del mondo sta succedendo qualcosa
di fantastico e noi magari non ce ne
stiamo rendendo conto
il grande vantaggio che abbiamo noi che
lavoriamo in italia è che come se
avessimo la macchina del tempo l'italia
su alcuni aspetti è più indietro e
quindi è più facile guardando altri
paesi che in alcuni ambiti specifici
sono più avanzati vedere quei trend che
probabilmente tra qualche anno
verranno anche sul nostro territorio noi
italiani siamo bravissimi poi ad
adattare quei trend alla nostra cultura
due anni fa stavo studiando un caso
incredibile che ho visto in america di
un'associazione che è riuscita ad
aumentare le adozioni dei cani dai
canili semplicemente inserendo i cani
attraverso dentro timber timbre e un'app
che penso conoscete tutti che diciamo
favorisce l'incrocio di ragazzi e
ragazze che vogliono conoscersi o di
qualunque sesso
e loro hanno avuto la brillante idea di
in 16 anche cuccioli quando vedo queste
scintille queste belle idee sono messo
nuovamente delle idee geniali mi viene
voglia di replicarle e quindi ho scritto
in rete chi mi vuole aiutare a far in
italia anche alcuni test e diversi amici
sono andati nei canili a fare le foto e
l'abbiamo poi provate ad importare
dentro kinder poi l'anno dopo però ad
ammettere anche le tartarughe di una
famosa onlus italiana sempre dentro la
piattaforma sono tutti i testi
interessanti a prescindere poi dalla
viralità che possano innescare la cosa
secondo me più interessante è proprio
questa attitudine a cercare continui
stimoli che poi alla fine è l'essenza
reale di un ted il ted dovrebbe
rappresentare un'idea che vale la pena
di essere condivisa il vero dramma sono
sicuro che sia la routine
tutti noi siamo completamente distratti
dal fatto che abbiamo troppe cose da
fare ogni singolo giorno il consiglio
che mi sento di dare ma più che altro
che sto provando a implementare nella
mia quotidianità è quella di cercare di
fare due esperienze ogni anno di
crescita personale che non devono essere
legate al mio ambito lavorativo
devo obbligarmi ad andare lontano a
cercare nuovi stimoli
vi ho anticipato l'opportunità che ha
avuto nel 2015 di andare alla singola
university l'anno successivo una breve
esperienza nel progetto ai dall'interno
di ospitato da harvard così come il mese
prossimo farò un tour di quattro città
della cina semplicemente per cercare
rapidamente di prendere un po di stimoli
per vedere quali sono più adatti per
essere importati anche nel nostro paese
se dovessi provare a sintetizzare gli
ingredienti che credo siano fondamentali
per generare viralità partirei
sicuramente dall'emozione bisogna
riuscire a toccare la corda di chi ci
ascolta per poi convincerlo a prende
parte attiva a una nostra campagna
secondo ingrediente sicuramente
l'entusiasmo
dobbiamo far venir voglia le persone di
alzarsi e di fare qualcosa insieme a noi
il terzo sicuramente la trasparenza non
possiamo ambire a coinvolgere magari
migliaia di persone se non siamo i primi
a dichiarare per filo e per segno anche
quali sono le motivazioni che ci hanno
portato a lanciare una simile iniziativa
mi auguro poi che il quarto ingrediente
sia l'etica questo non ho per niente per
scontato perché abbiamo visto tantissimi
casi
di utilizzo di tecnologia per generare
un impatto su migliaia di persone ma
magari cercando di generare un impatto
negativo e non positivo
una frase un'attitudine che vorrei
aggiungere a questi ingredienti è quella
di provare a imparare a dare sempre
senza aspettarci niente in cambio
con la mia futura moglie spesso
raccontiamo questo stile di vita come la
volontà di provare ad essere sempre a
credito quindi provare a dare agli altri
senza aspettarsi niente in cambio perché
se ti aspetti che torni qualcosa dopo
qualche settimana smette di dare perché
nel breve non ti torna mai niente e
quindi questa filosofia di vita secondo
me è molto importante ma anche se
riuscissimo ad utilizzare tutti questi
ingredienti non è comunque necessario se
prima non abbiamo creato una mini
community un gruppo di persone che
veramente capisce le nostre motivazioni
e rappresentano la prima base sulla
quale costruire un attività e virale per
questo anche per gioco quasi due anni fa
in cominciato a lanciare un'iniziativa
che è quella delle cene aperte siccome
non riesco mai a incontrare tutte le
persone che vorrei incontrare un comun
c'e da dire che è questo il mio kalender
queste sono tutte le città in cui sono
presenti per lavoro chiunque può
avvenire raggiungermi qualunque sera a
cena e questa cosa è nata un po per
gioco però è cresciuta tanto nel tempo
si sono create tantissime connessioni di
vario tipo
le scene non nascono con un obiettivo
quindi è semplicemente venite magari
potete chiedere un consiglio a me sono
sicuro che il consiglio migliore quello
era un altra persona che non accenna
senza neanche conoscere conoscermi
anche perché quando ho iniziato a fare
queste ce ne ero convinto che tra
qualche anno
io mi occuperò di qualche idea che
ancora non conosco qualcuno me lo
racconterà con persone che ancora devo
incontrare quindi in modo migliore una
contaminazione pura la cosa più
incredibile è che la giornata più bella
e più emozionante della mia vita
probabilmente avvenuta grazie alla
conseguenza di una cena a una cena è
venuta una persona che ha superato
l'imbarazzo di venire al tavolo con
tutte persone che non conosceva tempo
tre giorni mi ha presentato uno degli
chef più importanti del mondo che è
stato mio complice nella serata in cui
ho chiesto alla mia futura moglie di
sposarci queste cene sono diventate un
qualcosa di una routine molto divertente
seppure anche faticose e organizzare e
l'ultimo post che ho fatto il 25 agosto
in cui volevo dire sono tornato dalle
vacanze vediamoci è diventato veramente
un caso virale sopra ogni aspettativa
quindi non è costruire a tavolino 771
mila visualizzazioni e lì è stato il
momento in cui ho conosciuto questa
persona per cui in pochi giorni ci siamo
ritrovati poi con giulia cena con questa
romantica dichiarazione d'amore e
vedremo tra qualche mese il real
coronamento di questo sogno
sono sicuro che se riusciamo a vivere
tutto questo approccio in maniera molto
spontanea senza sapere dove vogliamo
arrivare
quando poi alzeremo la mano per chiedere
il supporto a un gruppo di persone
saranno i primi a volerti aiutare se
hanno riconosciuto in the una
spontaneità
se la provate a costruire in maniera
artificiale seguendo una lista di azione
tutto questo non non funzionerà vi
racconto qualche rapida esperienza fatta
con qualche amico due anni fa è stato un
inverno molto freddo e un amico alberto
scrisse un post dicendo servono le
coperte per i senzatetto
perché la temperatura sta per calare in
tutta onestà
era la vigilia di natale siamo sempre
stimolati da tantissime cause non ho
sentito mia quella causa e quindi non ha
fatto niente
due settimane dopo giulia la mia futura
moglie stava tornando a roma dopo aver
passato le feste a brindisi sono andato
alla stazione di roma incontrarla
solo che il treno ha fatto mezz'ora di
ritardo la temperatura è calata di 10
gradi e mi sono trovato per mezz'ora al
freddo di termini e quindi veramente la
ho sentito un emozione emozioni avere il
famoso freddo nelle ossa in quel momento
per puro caso un altro amico scrisse le
coperte che voleva alberto oggi sono in
saldo in una famosa catena di
arredamento per la casa
sapevo di avere un buono per quella
catena perché avevo comprato un mobile
restituito senza poi prenderne un altro
quindi quando giulio cesare al treno in
maniera quasi un po ironica disse amore
sono due settimane che non ci vediamo
vorrei portarti da ikea adesso posso
dire se pure non c'è nessuna
pubblicità occulta andiamole che ha e la
cera il grande dubbio avevo diciamo un
buon budget da poter investire perché
questo buono ma ci hanno educato che la
vera beneficenza si fa in silenzio
quindi volevo attivare la community
senza però fare diciamo in qualcosa di
troppo eclatante quindi di samone 61
tela foto la pubblico e disse quale ha
conoscendo di so che lo fai con uno
spirito buono ma vedrai che magari il
31esimo commento è negativo a tutti
concentri sul 31º quindi evita di
pubblicare la foto ho deciso comunque di
pubblicarla dicendo può semmai al
massimo la la cancello quello che è
successo e che per ora venerdì sera se
qualcuno avesse fatto una donazione
io l'avrei vista due giorni dopo e
lunedì mattina e quindi ha detto non
fate una donazione ora ho semplicemente
messo online google forum in cui
chiedeva miei amici di scrivere il nome
il cognome e quanto si impegnavano a
donare senza fare in quel momento una
donazione perché era molto più veloce la
sera stessa siamo andati con giuria
distribuire delle coperte ea un certo
punto ha visto che sono incominciate
arrivare tantissime e mail così tante
che per tre giorni consecutivi
abbiamo completamente svuotato ikea
abbiamo svuotato talmente tante volte
che al terzo giorno ci chiama e ci dice
guardate non abbiamo viste tante
iniziative questa nata così dal basso da
un gruppo prima e ramon 2 poi diventiamo
5 poi diventiamo 10 vogliamo aiutarvi
anche perché ogni volta che andavo
magari incontrava un amico questo era un
mio studente che mi hanno detto non solo
l'ho letto non ho voluto scriverti mi
hai fatto venire voglia di andare a
comprare le coperte senza neanche
delegare a te la scocciatura di uscire
di casa
quindi quando poi ci ha chiamati che ha
ci ha donato 10 mila ero ricoperte ho
sentito una responsabilità molto più
grossa di quello che è un gruppo di
amici poteva gestire e quindi gli ho
chiesto siccome voglio distribuirle in
poco tempo e in maniera più pratica
possibile per favore delle si pulisce le
in sei città in modo da diminuire il
numero di coperta in ogni città
ho chiamato poi le varie associazioni
nazionali dicendogli non ne do nessuna
di voi ne do alla prima che la va a
ritirare in ciascuna città con questo
codice dunque provato a creare scarsità
e urgenza in questa maniera
nelle sei città sono andate tubero tutte
a ritirarle il sesso giorno era la prima
foto quella cavo il dubbio se
pubblicarla oppure no
mi dicono
torino che abbiamo una sorpresa per te
la sorpresa era un calciatore paolo di
barra dell'argentina che aveva visto un
iniziativa ha detto io voglio aiutare
questo ragazzo non lo conoscevo
personalmente uno dei miei studenti
collabora con lui gli ha fatto vedere il
post paolo non solo è venuto ma ha
chiamato anche il calciatore di un'altra
squadra di calcio questo è diventato un
caso prima nazionale e poi è diventato
un caso internazionale arrivato fino in
argentina
sicuramente è diventato molto più virale
di quanto ci aspettavamo e anche di
quanto forse ci meritavamo e da quel
momento comincia da dire non mandare più
soldi
fate piccoli gruppetti e replicate
questa iniziativa quindi al diversi
amici di diversi contesti hanno fatto la
stessa attività dopo una certa soglia e
le campagne e vivono di vita propria e
quindi continua ad arrivare
tantissimi capi d'abbigliamento e
piuttosto che cappotti ci siamo trovati
pieni di materiale esattamente quando
c'è stato il terremoto in italia quindi
in questo piccolo di materiale abbiamo
guardato la croce rossa che ha
distribuito anche agli italiani che si
trovavano nelle palette questo è un caso
nel quale la vera forza è stata quella
del gruppo io mi son sentito e ho
privilegiato come organizzatore della
partita di calcetto ma la partita
l'abbiamo fatta tutti insieme
soprattutto ci tengo a dire che queste
iniziative non serve un esperto di
social media come è apparso in
televisione per organizzarle ciascuno
può organizzarle a vari livelli quindi
non fatevi ingannare dal fatto che
queste cose si costruiscono a tavolino e
sono alla portata di pochi se no il
messaggio della viralità sarebbe del
tutto artificiale
ci tengo a raccontare in questa bella
occasione con voi un'altra iniziativa
che sto lanciando in questo periodo
perché mi sono reso conto che
nell'ultimo anno il fenomeno più
importante è stato quello dell'influenza
l'influenza marketing esistono persone
in grado di influenzarne altre a fare
delle azioni che possono essere andare
in un ristorante comprare un prodotto
oppure magari seguire un particolare
stile di vita quindi mi sono chiesto se
le influenze sono delle vere calamite
che attirano le persone perché non
permettiamo alle persone di incontrarle
ma nel tramite devono fare un'attività
ad impatto sociale
ho ripreso un test che ho fatto qualche
anno fa con un amico attore dove avevo
organizzarlo semplicemente quale un'idea
volete conoscerlo venite però prima
donate il sangue e dopo potete fare
colazione con lui
quindi io ti mette in contatto con il
personaggio pubblico ma nel frattempo
deve fare un'azione sociale
questa cosa ho provato a farla scalare
levando ogni singolo paletto il paletto
era la donazione del sangue
abbiamo detto replicavano in ogni altro
contesto chiamato un amico che era un
campione della virtus di roma di basket
si è messa a disposizione con la sua
fidanzata altro personaggio pubblico
della televisione per incontra le sue
fan ma mentre si incontravano dovevano
necessariamente pulire quattro quartieri
di roma quindi passare del tempo con le
influenze per fare un qualcosa di
positivo
gli esempi di questo tipo ve ne potrei
raccontare tanti come per esempio la
voglia di andare con influenzerà pulire
insieme delle spiagge e in questo caso
un'altra influencer molto forte in
italia come giulia calcaterra dato la
disponibilità per fare attività simili
con i suoi fan oppure con il campione
europeo di cifre con makers abbiamo
organizzato il primo torneo di fifa dove
per partecipare non potevi pagare per
iscriverti dovevi donare dei giochi per
che poi sarebbero andate a delle case
famiglia e le declinazioni sono
ovviamente mille io mi mi piace
raccontare sperando che qualcuno le
possa poi copiare e chiudono nel fare un
esempio la differenza tra due mele e due
idee
sì abbiamo 2000 e ce le scambiamo alla
fine avremo sempre una mela testa mentre
sappiamo due idee ce le scambiamo
andremo a casa ciascuno con due dee con
questa logica cerco di raccontare questa
iniziativa in più contesti possibili
come per esempio importante università
abbiamo dette ragazzi che
rappresentavano 35.000 studenti nel
mondo scrivete nel gruppo con sap della
vostra università questa idea e provate
a replicarla anche voi così come
settimana scorsa mi sono trovato in una
giornata di formazione con randy
zuckenberg che è stata per dieci anni
direttore marketing di facebook nel
pochissimo tempo a disposizione che l'ho
raccontata per dire spero che anche voi
la possiate replicare per cui spero che
queste piccole scintille che ho provato
a darvi siano state minimamente di di
ispirazione e chiudo con una frase che
nella vita poi ottenere tutto quello che
vuoi
se aiuti le altre persone ad ottenere
tutto quello che loro
vogliono coni prima date per poi avere
grazie
[Musica]